well good afternoon everybody and thank
you for
name is Paul Moravsky and I head up
here at Yale University I'd like to
first thank the IT folks react asking me
to speak a little bit about my
department and you know you're probably
all wondering you know why does why am I
going to speak what is what is marketing
or licensing have to do but actually
because we manage the Yale marks on a
university basis all departments we
touch all departments in one way shape
or form over the course of the year but
before I start just give you a little
bit about my background I have been
fortunate enough to work at Yale for
about three years
I have been in the marketing a licensing
business my entire life about 40 years I
come primarily at a department store
world with 17 years in department stores
and I had my wife had my own consulting
business and prior also headed licensing
and retail for the American Museum of
Natural History in New York City
at Yale and like I said I've been here
three years and they also sit on the
committee the Yale Committee for
cooperative research what I'd like to do
is is take you a little bit through a
little bit about what we do and
basically it comes down to three issues
that my department handles I mean first
is we take care of protection of the
Yale marks secondly we try to establish
a marketing platform for the floor of
the Yale brand globally and third we
manage the licensing so that we actually
bring an additional revenue to the
university through license through the
licensing contracts that we provide and
just thought to just to start with I
thought I'd give you a little overview
of some of the things that we do
regarding protection of brands things
that we look at in order to make sure
the Yale brand is managed appropriately
and the people that we find we have the
most concerns with there a lot of times
outside contractors will want to use the
L name because they've done construction
in the unveil or they've produced a book
for Yale or whatever so what they like
to do is they'd like to take the Yale
name put it on their website well
actually you can't do that if that's
actually illegal it's actually it's
actually a misuse of trademark so we run
into a lot of those issues we run into
issues with the power companies misusing
our names we've run into that especially
overseas recently in Taiwan and in
mainland China
there's also been a case where I
company was using the Yale kindergarten
which obviously they can't do I'm so
there's a lot of different things that
we try to get in front of so that the
problems don't occur and that we can
actually make it so it's easy for the
people who can use the Yale marks to do
it appropriately
so first what we've done is we put some
pegs in the ground some guidelines for
how to use the Yale brands you know
starting with outside consultants and
contractors and the most important thing
there is that basically it's not allowed
you can't promote sponsor a proof
outside consultants or contractors or
any goods or services regardless of the
relationship with Yale so it doesn't
matter who the company is how big they
are they can't use the Yale brand
because Yale is a not-for-profit
institution and it cannot seen as
endorsing a a corporate venture with
related to commerce so secondly the
other area we target is are the students
and we love our students and you know
they're very creative in the way they
want to use the young marks and it's
very interesting to see some of the
things they come to us with well so what
we wanted to do is we wanted to create
put pegs in the ground for the students
so they clearly understood how to use
the Yale mark but also not if not to
crimp their creativity Sal shall we said
because usually see some of the things
that come across our desk when it comes
time for the Harvard football games or
some of the events that the students run
in the dorms so we have to be cautious
of that so what we've done is we put
together a guideline for the students it
was spurred on by the secretary of the
university who has the actual rights to
use the marks as the she see fits or her
authorized agents which happens to be
our department so any student group that
wants to use the Yale name has to first
register with us with a student
organization whether it's undergrad or
grad to make sure they are a legitimate
no they are a legitimate entity of the
University and also they have to make
sure they comply with the university
standards regarding the guidelines
associate the use of the marks now we've
established these along with the Office
of General Counsel and they include
things like your logo and name must be
at MIT must identify it was a student
organization you have to convey
in any way that you present your
organization that includes on your
emails on your website on any
paraphernalia or or swag that you want
to buy so we have to convey that student
or affiliation which you see some
examples here secondly a lot of students
say what can I can I can convey my
affiliation but yell by saying at Yale
but actually you can't at Yale is tied
to the Shops at Yale downtown so you
can't use that yell that does not allow
you to comply with the idea of being us
being a student organization and
relationship to the university use of
logos this is business this is always
very interesting because this is where
the students get creative and certainly
we encourage that but things like you
have to indicate that you're a student
organization like the Yale undergraduate
Chamber Orchestra the two groups of
marks that they're labeled able to use
are the Yale block and the Yale why but
when using those two logos you cannot
alter them so in other words we get
let's say swag for an event that one of
the one of the colleges are going to use
they can present it to us they can say
Yale but they can't alter those two
marks also acronyms if you use an
acronym you also have to indicate that
you're a student organization as you see
here and items to be distributed this is
my favorite so if you use the word Yale
and your name and logo you also have to
conclude that you're a registered
student organization so you see here the
Yale refugee project underneath it it
says an undergraduate organization which
is very important to note because the
way you have to think about it is a
student from one of the colleges puts
together a t-shirt that has something
that is could be considered offensive
that student goes to New York City on a
Friday night goes to Grand Central
Station is seen by thousands of people
that's the image that Yale is now
portraying to the world out there so we
have to be very cautious and when we
look at something in my departments how
does the world see it how is the John Q
public on a C Yale in that context and
that's how we judge whether it's
appropriate or not and of course the one
thing we also keep in mind is you can't
use orange and you can't use red because
you don't
Princeton or Harvard but anyway so
websites that's another favor this is
this actually running for this issue
more than any because it's really it's
really nothing students don't want to do
do it wrong they just don't understand
the guidelines associated with that so
something like making sure you have that
your logo conspicuously on the website
and importantly you have to have a
disclaimer because every student
organization is also insured by Yale so
having that disclaimer is important to
let it know that it's a student
organization not a Yale University
organization and also the email address
is associated to that have to be yell
email address you can't Stu do Gmail at
Yale comm that's not allowed if you're a
student organization have to tie to the
whatever websites using whatever email
address that the student in charge of
the group has so now you think about
okay now you do the brand protection
very important part of it this is an
idea last year in 2018 fiscal 2018 we
actually dealt with a hundred and forty
four cases globally of misuse of the
Yale marks that's across the world
majority here in the United States but
also we ran into an Asia we ran into in
Europe Matt ran into in the Middle East
so those types of things all come across
our desk so the ideas and say okay what
is he a licensing have to do with that
but if you think about it for a minute
if we're able to market the Yale brand
properly and we get it out there in as
many venues as possible people gonna see
it's gonna become more popular is gonna
become more important and people and say
well gee you know I see yell out there a
lot do we really want to do something
that's gonna infringe on that so the
license does not only bring in royalty
to the university but also prevents the
license from being abused and this is an
example of that like I say we had 144
misuses last year this year we've only
had 72 so it is improving it's never
gonna be perfect it's almost like
whack-a-mole sometimes the number of
number of issues we get so it's
important that we continue to market the
market the brand licensing appropriately
and that is actually a protection and
umbrella for the Yale brand so licensing
what exactly is licensing there's a lot
of questions to it of how does it work
what's the purpose of it and how is it
managed licensing at Yale is Yale
allows a company let's say champion
sportswear to use its name to market the
champion and yell brand together and
pays a royalty to the University that
royalty goes back to the University in
to the student scholarship funds so not
only do we do do we do a service by
marketing it through a particular brand
but we also do a service by bringing the
by bringing cash back into the
university we're actually one of the few
totally self-sufficient departments in
the entire college we don't take any
money from you everything we make
salaries benefits etc all come from
licensing revenue and we are employees
of Yale of course but we take our money
from the actual deals that we are able
to pull together within licensing so one
of the things we do and we're actually
we're actually trying to be a little bit
more aggressive and that is how do you
get the Nate Yale name out there
globally I mean you look out there the
most popular brand the edge brand in the
world as you see a like you wouldn't
believe that but it is UCLA action it's
31
UCLA stores and shine itself the issue
is people and it's the same thing in
Europe people don't understand that UCLA
is a university they just think it's a
logo so you think about that how much
money they're making just because they
think their brand is a logo
couple that with the power of our brand
the power the education behind Yale and
makes us a powerful entity that we want
to get out there and tell people about
not the way UCLA does but to truly speak
to the to the essence of Yale so how do
you do that we've done this a couple
ways we now as a university aggressively
attend all licensing or major licensing
shows throughout the world we just came
back from the Las Vegas licensing Expo
which is the largest in the world over
40,000 people attended we were the we
were the only University there next
month up they'll be traveling to Mumbai
I'm gonna be doing the licensing show in
Mumbai our booth is gonna be right next
to Oxford's and in next month I'm gonna
be traveling to Shanghai to the shanghai
licensing show we'll be right next to
Cambridge and in October will be doing
the brand licensing Expo in Europe and
to secure brands in that continent so we
take a very aggressive approach to get
the Yale brand out there internationally
and also do the protection of it and law
and licensing of it from Adam s
the perspective so when we're pitching a
license or a particular company how do
you do that I mean how do you say to
somebody hey do you want the yel brand
or they say to you can I have the ill
brand it's a very interesting dichotomy
because I would say 75% of the time
people come to us ask for use can we use
the yel brand well yes you can but
there's parameters that go around it we
have to understand the quality of the
brand we have to understand what kind of
company you have we have to understand
that a social rights every licensee at
Yale University has to be a member of
the Fair Labor Association to ensure
that they are protecting the workers no
matter where they are in the world
and one thing that we're actually very
proud of last year or I guess it was two
years ago there was an issue with one of
our licensees and I'm proud to say it
was Yale Cornell Georgetown in the
University of Washington actually put
pressure on this very large brand to
change their ways in the Vietnam and it
worked and that brand was Nike Nike does
not want us here that Yale pulled away
from them because we're doing something
illegal overseas so I'm proud of the
fact that Yale has that that I guess
check and balance to make sure you don't
run into those problems and if we do we
have the help of the Fair Labor
Association to deal with that so when
we're pitching to a brand or brands
pitching to us we want to give you an
idea of how we do that and how we speak
to that and how it then becomes a
partnership with us as the licensing
partner revenue the university marketing
of the Yale brand so the first thing you
want to do is you want tell them about
the university what you what they love
to hear about is the history and the
panache of an Ivy League institution
founded in 1701 renowned Ivy League
institution
what's the Yale mission and we explain
the Yale mission but also how does
licensing products speak to that Yale
mission it does because it helps to
serve and promote the brand throughout
the world and of course they want to see
what Yale looks like because if we're if
I'm in Mumbai or I'm in Shanghai or Las
Vegas people say have an envision of
Yale but what is it really like so being
able to show potential licensees what it
looks like you get the wow factor and
say well I really want to be associated
with that University I was right to come
to the licensing booth and try to get
that brain
so yell by the numbers and the next
question you always get when you're
talking to a potential licensee is how
big is yell how many people go to yell
what'swhat's the alumni so that type of
information very important and the thing
that people always look at we have
144,000 living alumni globally which is
very importantly special you're speaking
to somebody overseas athletics plays a
huge look how huge rolling Yale if you
think about that all the licenses that
we have here about 144 licenses globally
the largest ones are related to
athletics primarily champion Under
Armour and so forth we speak to the
teams that are related to that we speak
to of course the harvard-yale game which
everybody wants to be a part of because
when you've got 60 or 70,000 people at
Yale for a weekend how great is that for
a brand and of course who came to yell
of course the bushes came together
the Clintons can't do they love to hear
the stories about that handsome Dan you
would think that okay he's a bulldog
well the Bulldogs from 1889 old this
mascot in the United States it was so
important that in our Japanese agent
actually did a whole program of Yale
vintage products based on handsome Dan
it was very very successful now we're
spreading that to other countries
including Korea and mainland China what
does the Yale brand mean what the Yale
brand means is a promise of excellence
when you think of yeah what do you think
about you think of an excellent
education well we want the product to
speak of excellence also only the finest
quality only the famous the best factors
only the best names in order to make
sure that we are presenting Yale in the
manner that it should be presented in
the logos and word marks most popular on
the Left University logo institutional
mark that is reserved for what we call
some better products it is it is the
Yale University logo itself and you
don't see that as much as you see some
of the other ones the athletic mark is
actually being played down a little bit
recently so it's not as popular as it
was the most important popular word mark
is the Yale block you're going to see
that problem at 70
five percent of the items that are out
there that are licensed by Yale other
word marks the wide yell Bulldogs Yale
University but the interesting thing is
if you think a yell university that
would be a big play really there's only
a big play in Asia it's actually only
actually only the Japanese market
actually uses that for product right now
as well as the United States vintage
logos this is becoming a real trend in
the market right now you go to any any
comp store that carries collegiate
products right now that whole vintage
look the look that went back to you know
the 50s and 60s becoming very important
again so you'll see that the leaning
bulldog the golf course logo the script
Yale University which we just used for a
program in the United States and
established 1701 now licensing at Yale
what exactly do we offer or can we offer
to somebody who wants to work with our
institution whoops there we go we [ __ ]
we want them to share a vision of
product excellence only the finest
quality we take a global approach we
just don't want to say hey we'll take
your license we'll take your money no
that's not the way it works the idea is
that we want to work with you to make it
successful the licensee make it
successful for the marketing of the Yale
brand and makes it successful for the
revenue that we're going to bring into
the institution and the idea that it is
we're one of the most prestigious
universities of in the world and the the
amount of materials the array of
materials that you have that you can use
to actually enhance the Yale brand as
from a licensing perspective is huge now
in the United States we have roughly one
hundred and forty domestic licensees you
see some of the main ones they're
largest being champion Under Armour of
course has our sideline deal so you see
that when you go to the football games
Nike used to have the sideline deal
doesn't any longer but still a good big
player Vineyard Vines we're the only
university in the United States to have
a collegiate license with Lululemon and
also 47 brands who does all a lot of
headwear especially for the a privately
big league baseball now some of the
companies that we do business with you
think that okay yet Yale's in the
bookstore yells in campus customs yells
with some other stores downtown
actually that's not the truth actually
Yale is all over the country and stores
that you wouldn't expect we were in
Neiman Marcus this year we're impact son
right now we were in Barneys where every
year when forever21
Dick's Sporting Goods fanatics so it's
not just downtown Broadway it's actually
a national program here in the United
States with a lot of major retailers now
around the world we also revamped our
entire licensing program around the
world to in order to have us a global
hand in all major markets includes the
Middle East Europe and Russia Hong Kong
Mainland China Japan South East Asia and
in Canada actually Canada is growing
nicely for us right now now who do we
work with around the world you wouldn't
expect these brands to see be associated
with Yale but they are championed Japan
would just signed champion Japan that
was a major program based on the success
of Jim champion United States and we're
now working in negotiating with champion
Taiwan two years ago we had a global
program with Zahra over 2,400 stores
worldwide this year we had a global
program with Calvin Klein you wouldn't
think Calvin climbing yeah but actually
we did actually we were a global program
with Calvin Klein and we actually had we
actually presented had in the runway in
Milan last July of Yale product along
with the University of California all
pulled together which was very very
successful now how you grow that you
have to think about it and one of the
questions you get well you know how do
you choose which license you want to use
well you have to take it approach a more
global approach who's the best one you
want to work with okay we work with
Calvin Klein so that it creates an
umbrella for the brand Zahra your fast
fashion but you also don't want to walk
away from somebody who is that maybe at
the opening price point like a prime
mark we do business which is a
london-based company we also do business
with winners in Canada we do business
with Walmart now the thought is here is
rehab so we have t-shirts in Walmart
right now and you say yourself oh you
know is that that Yale is that is that
who Yale wants to present to well
actually it is do you think about it
there's gonna be people in this world
will never see the Yale University
campus they'll only see it on TV they
may never be able to get to yell but by
having a t-shirt the opening price point
feeling a part of the one was famous
universes in the world and we're
inspired by that and we believe in that
so that's why we also sell to your
Walmart or the world
yours areas of the world to McAlary
carry the brand of Calvin Klein and how
we break down jumped a little bit but
that big blue area is actually a power
as the largest part as you would imagine
and within that again is this slide
jumped a little bit but men's a power
represents about two-thirds of the peril
that we do and this jumped a little bit
too and the non apparel the largest area
would be in school products such as
back-to-school backpacks paper goods etc
recently I see any programs in the Yale
just to give you an idea of some of the
things that have happened recently for
us to give you an idea where we're
taking the brand Yale co-op shirt I
don't know how many people remember the
old co-op shirt from gantt years and
years ago it's been around since 1949
Gantt decided they didn't want to work
with us anymore back in 2014 we've now
relaunched that through Vineyard Vines
and that's the ad that ran the alumni
magazine this past year this past month
Lululemon as I mentioned we're the only
university in the United States to carry
the Lululemon brand and vice versa
forever 21 we run a program every year
with forever 21 extremely popular this
is the one that we ran this fall and
Calvin Klein this product ranged
anywhere from a few dollars up to over
$2,000 for the product depending what
you purchased that cashmere that code on
all the way on the left that the young
man is wearing that's a $25 cashmere
coat they produced only six of them
worldwide and sold them primarily in
Europe and of course Zara this is the
global brand that we did was our two
years ago and just some other examples
for you see here these are some things
that are going on right now you see your
traditional you look on the left you see
the leaning bulldog part of PAX Sun and
the other tooth that's actually JC
Penney's website when I carried the
store actually on JC Penney's website
which is what speaks very highly of us
and here's some examples of the women's
brand so yes we have t-shirts that you
would expect and we carry a plethora of
those but also other looks that are
exciting that are fashion forward so
that Yale is not only your t-shirt your
sweatshirts but something a little bit
high
and some of the noun are not apparel
things and these are some fun items that
we carry that we actually make here and
we actually manage this process for
these items here right in our office
this is called the Yale collection and
these are items they're only available
online you see that the stadium there
you see handsome dancer best seller a
replica football from the 1920s again
licensing product that you wouldn't
expect the Yale Bowl this is a hand-cut
ceramic bowl every piece is slightly
different that retails for $600 we've
already sold four of them downtown in
the dwell store and of course
accessories very popular tote on the
Left actually includes a map of these
town of New Haven inside it the little
bracelet that's actually a mini map of
Yale in there so we try things are
different unusual things you're not
going to expect out there so what does
the Yale licensee program Wofford it's
an evergreen brand always going to be
there we've been here for three hundred
years or gonna be here for three hundred
more a wide range of intellectual
properties you steal the number of marks
that were offered local representation
so that we can actually work with the
brand to make it successful and an
engaged management team which we like to
think we are in our office so that gives
you an idea of what we do it with the
licensee department how it intertwines
so not only do we manage the licensing
royalties that come in we manage the
brands we manage the property of Yale to
make sure that is actually as pristine
as it should be thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you